[Music]
I'm on a one-day break from touring with
Jordan Peterson and joining me in studio
today is a free-speech lawyer and the
director of the individual rights
defense program at the foundation for
individual rights in education
aka fire ah Rico and welcome to the
Reuben report thanks for having me
that was a wordy intro a lot of freedom
stuff in there and that's all the stuff
that I like so I'm looking forward to
this say so you guys fire as an
organization is one of the the few
bastions of sanity these days like when
I see what you guys are tweeting about
and consistently defending the
principles of free speech and free
expression and open inquiry I'm always
like ah there are some good guys left so
first can you just tell me a little bit
about the organization why you guys got
started how you personally got involved
well we got started in 1999 with a
professor at Penn and a civil liberties
lawyer in Philadelphia who we're you
know they both decided that there were
there was a problem there was an
epidemic at our colleges and
universities of the core individual
rights that that make up you know our
our Constitution if you will as
individuals as people as citizens of the
United States
we're being respected on campuses across
the country back in 99 99 yeah that's
interesting because a lot of people say
this is just the totally recent
phenomenon well I think you know a lot
of it the there is the political
correctness movement of 80s and 90s a
little bit you know that might have had
something to do with it but then this
has been a problem since the Free Speech
Movement back at Berkeley you know long
before even the 80s or 90s you know
censorship is an age-old problem it
predates the United States of America
really and as Alan and Harvey you know
went about creating fire and they
decided to locate it and like located in
Philadelphia which is you know the
birthplace of our nation they really got
an outpouring of people saying hey this
happened to me too and they said well
this is you know this is a problem this
is an epidemic we need to fix
and fire I was born or lit if you will
and over the years I getting close to 20
now crazy enough that has actually just
gone up every year more and more people
reach out to fire for help you know when
I got to fire for the second time
actually was a legal fellow of fire
after I graduated from law school before
I started in private practice but when I
came back in 2013
getting several hundred K submissions a
year and now we're getting damn near
close to a thousand a year and that's
just the stuff that we hear about can
only imagine how much other stuff is
going on around the country for people
who don't know that we're out there to
help them or you know people who perhaps
go about it themselves it's it's crazy
to think about how much is going on yeah
so I want to talk about some of those
cases and some of the specific work that
you're doing
but foundation for individual rights in
education I am a believer right now
partly because of Kanye West and because
of a lot of people online right now that
the individual is making a comeback that
the idea of the individual verse the
collective is actually making a comeback
do you have any idea when they came up
with the name for fire why it was so
important to put the individual front
and center well I think it's you know
and I'm speaking you know out of some
level of ignorance because I haven't
actually discussed this with either of
them personally but you know if I had to
guess it's it's because the the
individual qualities the freedom of
conscious the freedom of speech the
things that allow us to participate in
society we don't get to the collective
unless we have the individuals one is
necessary to have the other because what
is a collective other than a group of
individuals and consensus is a bunch of
individual opinions that throughout the
process of winnowing and debating
different good ideas and bad ideas we
reach a common understanding we reach a
you know a norm for society and that's
how that's why free speech particularly
is so important
that's how we get to the optimal
resolution the optimal conclusions
that's how we reach these communal
positions is only through our own
personal expressions of what we believe
which exposes us to criticism or
agreement or just flat-out discussion
with other people so how do you think
the ideas of the collective took root so
much at college campus then well I think
there's the give-and-take in society at
large that we really go through every
once in a while in terms of thinking
about things as individualistic and then
worrying about broader concerns of the
community and that's not altogether a
bad thing and I think the college campus
and it's always been this way it's a
microcosm of what we're experiencing in
the broader society and I think that's
another reason why it's so important to
protect individual rights on college
campuses because where they fall on
college campuses they're almost
certainly sure to fall in society writ
large yeah so that actually we discussed
this briefly right before the cameras
turned on that's my concern about this
when people will say oh you know there
isn't a free speech issue on college
campuses and even though I keep going to
college campuses and it's very clear to
me that there is a free speech problem
there but it's not what's gonna happen
it's not just these screaming kids right
now it's not that it's that these are
the people that are going to be in
leadership positions 5 10 15 years in
the future and further than that
obviously and if those ideas take root
because they were able to silence us
once they are the lawmakers once they're
in charge of public policy they're not
going to be too kind to the people who
they were silencing way back when right
yeah I mean that's really one of the key
problems and it's not even just if they
get elected to power even if they aren't
elected and they don't rise to power and
they can't impose these views on other
people these are future citizens even if
they're not necessarily future leaders
and then discourse of the nation if that
is the the prevalent feeling in society
is going to suffer tremendously as a
result if even if they're not in
Congress or in the state legislatures if
50 percent
the country's population thinks that we
shouldn't be talking about certain
things we're not going to talk about
these things and it's going to be
societally imposed if nothing else and I
think that's incredibly damaging to just
about every aspect of our life as a
country yeah it's so interesting to me
because I know used you read about this
but I was at the University of New
Hampshire a couple weeks ago and you
know first we were supposed to give a
speech on campus then about two hours
before they announced that they couldn't
secure the room that they felt there
were too many threats so they were about
200 or 250 people supposed to be in the
room they moved us to the hockey rink
which seats 7,500 people so I stood in
front of a little you know backdrop and
I talked to about 200 people it was
about 150 people that were there to
listen and be respectful and all that
stuff and then they were about probably
about 50 protestors roughly those are
the rough numbers but the desire just to
shout down to use noisemakers to scream
to chant like robots they love robotic
chants all of these things and I kept
saying to them guys do you have any
direct questions is there something that
I've said that you disagree with or is
there something you directly like to ask
me and time and time again the answer
was no and I don't know how you break
them out of that other than keep having
these conversations and hope that the
refugees make it to us and that's a
common problem I think it really comes
down to ideological purity that people
are after the idea that if I disagree
with you on something whether small or
even fundamental if I disagree disagree
with you on that one thing that means
nothing that you have to say could
possibly be of value to me and that is
completely false then you couldn't be
farther from the truth
we can learn so much from the people we
disagree with the most even if I
disagreed with you on absolutely
everything it would still be incredibly
valuable for me to talk to you if only
because that helps me sharpen and really
understand why I believe what I believe
in and people really discount the
importance of understanding why you
believe something yeah so the argument
that I've been making for a while is
that and I do think right now at least
in 2018 this is more of a problem on the
left
but they've only ideas in the narrative
and the college campus discussion and
academia and media and all that they've
owned that for so long that the reason
these kids end up be or these students
end up being so hysterical is because
they never hear counter ideas so then
you get a pretty moderate guy who's
arguing about liberty and freedom for
everybody and live and let live and that
actually offends them because they never
hear anything outside of what they're
being taught that goes to the academic
part I think mostly well I think we're
doing a really crappy job of educating
students before they get to college
about why free speech and our other
rights are important civics education is
clearly in the toilet right now yeah
and it's bizarre to me I grew up in
Skokie Illinois one of the sites one of
the most famous free speech cases you
know in recent history
yeah can you lay it out for those that
don't know this the story in the 70s the
American the American Socialist Party
that nationalist party the Illinois
Nazis if you'd ask the Blues Brothers
yeah wanted to march through Skokie
Illinois which outside of New York had
the largest concentration of Holocaust
survivors in the United States and
Skokie tried to stop them and they sued
with the aid of the American Civil
Liberties Union of Illinois and it went
too well both the Supreme Court of
Illinois and the Supreme Court of the
United States and the Nazis had the
right to march and and the courts held
so and there were threats of violence
and disruption and all you know people
out crying as to how this could be
allowed but ultimately the Nazis had the
First Amendment right to march through
Skokie and I grew up learning about that
case from a very young age I can't tell
you how many times I saw the movie they
made about it yeah and it really it got
me thinking at a young age about why
this is important how I think about it
and I can't tell you that as a young
child I completely agree that the Nazi
should have a right to march you know I
when I was that young a part of me
didn't grasp the overarching fundamental
importance of free speech but I was
thinking about it
yes and I got there and I get the
feeling that some
we're not doing enough to make our
students think about why it's important
yeah it's such an important case and I'm
glad you mentioned it because it goes
really to the heart of this that the
people that lived in Skokie as you said
the second largest amount of Holocaust
survivors in the country these people
literally survived the genocide probably
virtually all of them lost some of them
probably lost all of their family
members and friends and all of that and
yet I would sit here as someone that
lost Holocaust survivors on both sides
of my family and tell you it was the
right decision you can't let the the
Nazis or the white supremacist whatever
they're you can't let them start
ransacking property you can't let them
start killing people are harming people
but letting letting them march that's
the exchange of free speech and it's
kind of shitty but you got to defend it
when it's hard to defend you that's
defined it when it's hard to defend
because otherwise there's it's not going
to be around to defend when it's easy to
defend you know once you can start
creating exceptions and encroaching
there's no end to it and you know we've
kind of seemed even in other countries
that once the the encroachments start
it's always well we make that exception
and just this one other small exception
and then there's inevitably another one
and another one and all four perhaps
even you know good reasons in terms of
you know ideals and and the goals are
laudable perhaps I say at every show the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions getting tired of saying me
both yeah but you know it's really
practically speaking it's inevitable
yeah how much of this is just a
confusion as to what the First Amendment
is that's also what I've started to
realize because when I've gone on
college campuses and the protesters are
there and I always say it I welcome
peaceful protests I completely welcome I
welcome the exchange of ideas the
questions all of that but when when
they're screaming about certain things I
think there's just a disconnect as to
what I think to legal things I think
what the First Amendment is and what
hate speech is is or isn't so can you
talk about that a little bit yeah I if I
had to have to hear one more person
whether it be student
Internet comment or even journalists or
faculty numbers sometimes say hate
speech is not free speech I'm gonna lose
it okay so let's do it let's do that one
first cuz I really I mean this will be
maybe what we promo for this episode but
I really want people to understand this
why is hate speech free speech well on a
legal level hate speech is free speech
because the First Amendment and the
courts have said nothing about freeze or
hate speech being unprotected by the
First Amendment speech is protected by
the First Amendment unless it falls
under one of the very few existing
categories of unprotected speech yeah
what are what are those categories
there's incitement to imminent lawless
action and these all have very high bars
true threats and intimidation you can be
sued for libel or slander defamation as
they're known some states I think
actually still have criminal statutes on
the book but books but they're rarely
enforced love fraud obscenity which
people often confuse with mere profanity
or lewdness but they are not the same
thing by any stretch of the imagination
what's the difference on those two well
profanity and lewdness are generally
protected by the First Amendment
obscenity is a very high bar it's a
speech that has to be our expression I
should say more broadly than just speech
that has to appeal to the prurient
interest which is an inordinate
fascination with sex describe or depict
sex in a patently offensive way and have
no social political literary or artistic
value whatsoever and to get down in the
in the mud he ever heard of crush videos
I feel like I have but I'm honestly not
sure what that is they are videos of
women wearing stilettos crushing small
animals like hamsters and gerbils to
death and people apparently get off on
that yeah I don't intend to understand
it even that is not wholly unprotected
by the obscenity exception to the First
Amendment that that's a particularly
interesting case I suppose because the
idea of it talking about it seems like I
would have no problem with that but the
action itself probably there's
legal reasons right like killing and
killing animals there's some law I guess
if Charlie state law right but if you
have this pornography you can call it
that I just have a hard time getting it
yeah if you have it in you to possess it
or like unit you can't be prosecuted for
for possessing that obscene material
it's an interesting distinction that the
Act is the crime or the act is what is
illegal not the depiction depiction or
is it disseminating of the information
or that sort of thing right child
pornography obviously not protected by
the First Amendment yeah you know but
there's some others the one additional
wrinkle of the fighting words doctrine
although there's a considerable doubt
that it remains a viable exception to
the First Amendment but it really gets
brought up a lot in the hate speech
debate to the extent it still exists
it's limited to face-to-face
interactions where say I say something
to you that is so insanely abusive that
you are likely to punch me in the face
without thinking twice about it instead
of taking a deep breath and either
ignoring me or coming back at me and
there's reasons why it's fallen into
disuse and it's worthwhile to note that
the Supreme Court hasn't upheld a
fighting words conviction since the case
in the 40s when it created the fighting
which is how far it's fallen into disuse
it incentivizes punching people in the
face right it creates an easy way to
censor the people that you disagree with
and it would I assume be some level of a
subjective piece of information as to
what you think is offensive at the
highest order is different perhaps than
what I think or exactly what some of
these other people yeah it creates
terrible incentives and it would
basically lead to an institutionalized
hecklers veto so it's really not tenable
yeah so on that on the hate speech front
which was clear what the Supreme Court
has said about hate speech you're
allowed to do it with with these
exceptions that you've just laid out
you're allowed to say mean things what I
what I'm realizing on college campuses
is they really don't like that the
people the set of people that we're
talking but they really don't like that
so like they think if you like
you it's just the fact you are allowed
to say bad things you can say I hate all
the Jews you can say I hate all the
black people and all the gays or
whatever you can say it you can't cause
direct call to violence but what I think
they think is that if you keep saying
those things I hate these people that
it's going to incite violence now my
counter-argument would be no you have to
use free speech to counter those bad
ideas that's the whole purpose of free
speech but do you see that that that
seems to be the slope that they
consistently are on that if we allow you
to say I hate these people which is
bigoted and prejudiced and all of those
things but it's afforded to us by the
Bill of Rights they think that that's
going to get you to violence how do you
combat that notion if you agree with the
premise well that is something that we
tend to hear a lot in the First
Amendment world and you know first of
all generally speaking in this country
we punish the people who do the bad acts
if I watch your show and I get some
kooky idea and go off and you know
commit some crime we're not going to
throw you in jail because I'm an idiot
and took a terrible idea that you didn't
even intend me to take right now it
might be different though if I was up
here saying you should violently attack
these people etc right exactly and
that's why the incitement standard is so
high he has to be likely to incite and
intended to incite immediate criminal
action so if I tell you hey you know it
would be fun to burn down a building but
you're not likely to do it you're gonna
take it as a joke I probably haven't you
know committed any kind of you know
unlawful expression if I know you're a
pyromaniac and I say hey Dave let's go
burn down a building I might you know
find myself in a very different
situation I think sort of left that
phase at about eight years old but
alright but you know I think that if you
take a look one of my colleagues
actually wrote a piece for a quill that
not so long ago about the Rwandan
genocide and looking over the claims
that the radio broadcasts actually you
know caused more violence and what it
turns out is that the radio broadcasts
first of all only incited people
who were already predisposed and who
already felt that way and it made it
marginally easier for them to find
people and you know be taught how to do
certain things but it was relatively
ineffective as it turns out in
convincing people who weren't already in
a murderous rage to go out and commit
violence and so you know I think that
the fear that allowing these views to be
aired is going to indisputably cause
actual violence is somewhat overblown
now there's a second part to it which is
that people expressing these views might
lead to more people adopting those views
and having prejudiced views is that
possible absolutely right so that's the
part I was revered but that's kind of
the point is that we put those views out
there so we can fight them mm-hmm if we
don't have them in public and we can't
fight them they're still gonna spread
nothing no idea ever went away because
we said you can't say that it just
doesn't work like that yeah how does the
hecklers veto fit into all of this
because one of the things that I again
see on college campuses is when heckler
starts screaming at you and you say just
a second you know if I'll get to your
question or calm down or whatever you
might say they'll say well I have a
right to free speech too as they try to
flip it on you to make you look like a
hypocrite that actually kind of kind of
gets me but I will give them a little
bit of credit I think you say a
university event and somebody comes in
and they chant for 30 seconds or they
stand up and turn their backs and that's
the extent of it I think that we should
protect that technically are they
causing a disruption
yes but it's minimal and it's actually
maximized the amount of free speech
there's to be some room for very minimal
disruption yeah but when it gets to the
point where they are substantially
interfering with the speaker's ability
to get their message across or the
audience's ability to hear them
through repeated shouting or noisemakers
or you know standing in the front and
blocking everyone's views and things
like that obviously that's a problem and
last year we just saw a rash of the
hecklers vetoes going on and it kind of
all started with Berkley and Miley
innopolis yeah when they protesters were
successful in shutting down the event
through of what had before that been
unfathomable on a college campus for an
invited speaker we've seen invited
speaker controversies since fire was
found in basically he never ever am i
aware of any incident that came close to
something like that it was just madness
yeah and they got away with it the so
few arrests were made and I can't help
but wonder if the students out at
Middlebury College where Charles Murray
was speaking seized on that and looked
at the Berkeley students and said well
they were successful in stopping that
event with speech that we also de tested
and they got away with it so let's try
that it's a viable tactic this might be
a solution for keeping this speech we
disagree with off campus and ideas like
that that the tactics that students are
able to successfully utilize they will
behavior that is rewarded essentially is
going to be repeated yeah and I see that
all over the place right now so for
example just a couple months after Milo
went to Berkeley and that happen Ben
Shapiro spoke there and it was largely
nonviolent but it cost the university
six hundred thousand dollars to make
that happen I mean I think an ATM was
broken and a couple windows and that's
it
but that's part of the tactic is if we
can keep ramping this up we'll keep
pushing the security cost and as I said
they had to move my event to a freakin
hockey theater that hockey arena that
couldn't have been cheap and and several
other than these I saw I'm sure you're
familiar of the case of Lindsey Shepard
up at Wilfrid Laurier in Canada
and she just had to crowdfund I think
around six grand to get security for one
of her events so that almost seems like
the new tactic it's almost like we don't
have to we can scare them with some
threats of violence and some other stuff
and then we'll cause the security costs
to be so high that you guys will just
give up well and that's another problem
we've been fighting since even before
all this came to a head is colleges and
universities trying to charge student
groups security fees for the speaker's
based on the anticipated protest or
controversy and that's plainly
unconstitutional it has been for a long
time since the Supreme Court said that a
listeners reaction is not a Content
neutral basis for regulation and you
cannot charge more for controversial
speakers because they might drop
protests that places a price tag on
expression and prices like you said
it'll price the controversial expression
out of the marketplace they're not going
to be able to afford it what student
group has 17,000 dollars to spend on
security
none of them yeah and you know what it
comes down to his administrators the
university itself has to be the
guarantor of last resort when it comes
to the speaker's ability to speak and
this is the business they are in and
sometimes it's unpleasant and sometimes
it costs a whole lot of money but if
you're not going to have a campus where
we can discuss things and we can debate
things even if it gets loud and
boisterous and raucous and contentious
which is everything free speech should
be yeah if your campus isn't going to be
a place where that occurs then what are
you what are you doing so I do want to
make a point of saying that some of the
campuses are getting it right and I'm
sure you know some of the campuses that
are doing a little better than some of
the others but for example at the
beginning of September 2017 I spoke at
Claremont McKenna at there they're doing
a big free speech push because of what
happened the semester before with
Heather McDonald and all hell broke
loose in on the campus and I was
completely welcome there and they even
some of the students who disagreed with
me I mean they asked healthy questions
and all of that good stuff so it's where
I
think it's worth mentioning that some
schools are doing their best to manage
some of this absolutely and on two
levels I think you know first of all
fire rates policies at schools we rate
over 400 different colleges and
universities on our red light yellow
light green light level red light being
you have policies that are clearly and
substantially unconstitutional yellow
light being you have policies that are
susceptible to being applied in bad ways
and green light schools where none of
their policies poses a serious threat to
free speech in the past couple years the
number of green light schools that we
have has nearly doubled which is
tremendous now still close to 60% of
schools have a yellow light so there's
work to be done but you combine that
with the 38 schools that have now put
out statements expressly committing
themselves to free speech something that
you know the University of Chicago
kicked off a while back there's reasons
to be hopeful and we work regularly with
administrators who are happy to have us
you know consult on their policies and
say you know here are the changes we
would make and we're we have amicable
relationships with so many
administrators which is really
gratifying but on the student side also
part of it is overblown I think by media
there are a lot of students out there
who do get it yeah and people of all
ideologies and all political you know
sides there are a lot of students out
there who get it I speak to them on a
daily basis and I there is a lot of
reason to have hope yes it's not a lost
cause no I agree I think it's important
talking about it because even again at
that university everything I
seventy-five percent of the crowd at
least was there respectfully decently to
hear ideas and do that what I felt was
important after and why I still want to
talk about and have you here and all
that is because I want people to be
armed with the right arguments so that
when these this set of people even if
it's just a smaller set that's just
really loud so as a disproportionate
amount of influence I want people to
understand there are tactics you can use
to fight it so I'm curious on that list
of 38 schools that's kind of doing it
right
right now when they've instituted some
of these policies and I remember
University of Chicago did it about a
year ago is there evidence that things
actually get better because I'm gonna
guess that when you give some rules some
of these students they don't want to be
kicked out of school and they might
actually behave better well so I think
you know this there's a lot of
conversation right now about some
legislation even that's going on about
disrupting speeches and mandatory
punishments for students who do so a
certain number of times and you know I
think that's actually less important and
I actually have somewhat of a problem
with laws that create mandatory
punishments for vaguely defined terms
like disrupt which you know could be
applied to pretty much anything that
sneeze you know it's um but I think more
important is when an administration is
saying hey these are the values that
really that this is the wellspring of
intellectual vitality that our
institution relies on mm-hmm these are
the the ideals you should be paying
attention to this is what's gonna make
your experience really worthwhile I
think students will listen to that
instead of maintaining the policies that
say thou shalt not say mean things about
your classmates that gets students in a
very different mindset when they come to
college right what what are the
statements or what are the principles
that you have you guys want to see in
those statement I the principles are
just largely this is a place of debate
this is a place of intellectual
exploration it is not our job as
administrators or as faculty members to
silence ideas that we find controversial
or protect you from them it is our job
it is our you know mission to expose you
even to ideas that you might disagree
with and give you the tools that you
need to analyze them think critically
about them formulate your own ideas and
participate in the conversation because
that's what you're gonna have to do when
you leave after four or however many
years you're here that's part of life in
our democracy is participation if you
don't participate then
you know there's the saying goes if you
don't participate you have no grounds to
complain we have to you know really get
students in the mindset that these are
important life skills and they're
important even in other instances in the
workplace they can be important if you
have a policy position if you're working
at a company that you think is either
bad or is one that you want to promote
you have to be able to think about the
people who disagree with you and what
they're going to say anticipate their
response and formulate an argument that
resolves it you know there's countless
situations in the world outside of
college where being able to think
critically is incredibly important and
really I think that you get a lot of
value out of doing that outside of the
classroom because it teaches you how to
contextualize the skill it teaches you
how to apply it not just in the I read
this assignment let's talk about it kind
of way cuz that's really not how life
works once you graduate I wish it was it
would make things a whole lot simpler
that you'd be out of a job probably
that's true I would have to find
something else to do alright so we
touched on the First Amendment a little
bit in the first half but I think
there's also just a fundamental
misunderstanding about what speech is
related to the First Amendment in that
the First Amendment basically is about
what the government is not allowed to do
and people have now extrapolated that to
think it means what everyone can't do
can you talk there's that famous xkcd
comment comic about people have the
right to tell you you're an [ __ ] on
the internet it doesn't violate the
First Amendment and that's true although
I definitely it all day long
I guess am I get that comic thrown at me
sometimes even when it's a government
institution doing the censorship so it's
it's overused a little bit too and that
kind of just gets in my craw a little
bit but the First Amendment really only
does protect you from the government and
it doesn't just protect you from
Congress it protects you from the states
it protects you from the MS
municipalities it protects you from the
public colleges and universities and
their administrators those are all state
actors for the First Amendment what it
doesn't protect you against is your
private employer which means that I
could well be fired for anything I say
this show today
see what I could do not to give you any
ideas yeah you know your parents don't
if you say I remember saying free speech
to my parents and I was very young
probably right after I read about the
Skokie case and my mother giving me a
side either they burn a hole through my
skull at this point yeah but you know it
only protects you against the government
it doesn't protect you from criticism of
your peers and your contemporaries and
it shouldn't you know that's kind of
part and parcel of having the public
conversation is if you have a bad idea
and you're out there spouting it we all
have the right to tell you you've got a
shitty idea yeah and we should say that
because otherwise well we might see that
shitty idea spreading and and that's
kind of the point
of like we were talking about earlier
about letting these terrible ideas out
there is so that we can stand up and
defeat them yeah are you seeing in any
major threats right now from the
government related to free speech
because a lot of times I'll see people
saying well Trump is attacking this sort
you know he attacks journalism a lot now
it's no secret what my feeling about the
mainstream media is these days I mean I
think it's it's largely just partisan
garbage and I don't think you should be
killing these people are harming these
people in any way just to be very clear
I hope that by mocking them and exposing
their nonsense we'll get a new
generation of better journalists and
people who really live to the code of
trying to find truth and all of that but
do you see a direct threat right now
coming from the government either from
Trump or elsewhere there's always a
direct threat yeah I mean let's be clear
people in power will always if given the
opportunity silenced their opponents
yeah they will preserve the status quo
and it's not just people in power it is
an entirely human reaction to want to
censor the people we disagree with we
think we have terrible ideas that's kind
of a base or instinct that we all have
now we have to overcome that and
understand the value of not doing that
but it's it's kind of understandable in
a way and that's why we have to be so
vigilant and protecting free speech
because once the tools are there they
don't go away and we've seen this
throughout history and their will
and I people laughed at me when I was
you know talking during the election
cycle to I guess kind of betray some of
my personal political leave said you
know I was kind of talking about how the
executive branch over reached as many
people did of the last administration
that was problematic because you know
what about the next guy who comes to
power maybe he's gonna do something
crazy and nobody bill laughed at me hey
I was talking about that thing I was
talking about it when butch was doing it
I was talking about it when Obama was
doing and I think about it they laughed
and then Donald J Trump was elected
president and I looked at them and I
said what now
and you know you you said oh it couldn't
be possible that somebody we disagree
with all that much who we think is
really terrible would ever get elected
president and when they started melting
down over the election I looked at them
and I said oh you're so yeah you can't
be for executive actions when it's the
guy you like but then not for them when
it's the guy you don't like of course
they're all going to do it if you give
them the power to do it and it's the
same thing with free speech and I think
what's really important to remember is
that those mechanisms those tools of
censorship are never ever going to read
out to the benefit of the marginalized
communities that people are oftentimes
seeking to protect it just doesn't
happen the reason they are marginalized
is that they don't have political power
they're not going to be the ones
implementing these rules and that's
incredibly problematic and people don't
understand that very practical reality
that those tools of censorship are going
to be used to defend the status quo
which is what these people are trying to
disrupt yeah a disruption is kind of
that just the major threat that everyone
in power feels and it we've seen it
throughout history that there in the
civil rights movement when protesters
were arrested for sitting at lunch
counters or for engaging in nonviolent
protest but were arrested for disorderly
conduct because people reacted to their
protests in
ways because they were violent bigoted
thugs they were only exonerated because
of the First Amendment that and it took
going to the Supreme Court and it's
really important to remember I mean how
many LGBT artists and authors and
publications faced censorship and had
their materials deemed obscenity at
times and not even sent through the mail
at you know sometimes before you know
they and preventing them from
integrating into the national
consciousness I mean it's it's really
really important yeah so is there
something happening right now via the
government that you think shouldn't be
happening
I get the broad sense sort of the the
blue sky version of this that yes people
in power always are gonna want to
maintain power do what they have to do
to silence people etcetera but at the
college and university level
specifically I think a lot of it is
coming from the Department of Justice
and the office for civil rights of the
Department of Education a few years back
had an agreement that they called a
blueprint for sexual harassment policies
at colleges and universities and it
basically defined sexual harassment is
any unwelcome conduct of a sexual nature
including verbal conduct which we also
know as speech yeah and the breathtaking
broadness of that policy really kind of
spread like wildfire and you know these
harassment policies have always kind of
been problematic at times this is
directly tied to title nine right yes
yeah and you know it's it's one of the I
don't know if it's even an unintended
consequence it might be a very well
unintended consequence but you start
seeing things a for example just the
number of years back there was a student
to the University of Oregon who was
sitting on the ledge in a dorm room
window and she saw a couple outside and
as a joke she shouted I hit it first
which I didn't even know what that meant
when it first came in and I had to look
it up and I realized that it was about
Ray J
having sex with Kim Kardashian Kanye I
guess that's a thing people care about
nowadays I don't know well you know
behind a is the leader in free speech
move up so boy maybe I do need to find
another job but anyways that the couple
was offended and ran upstairs and talked
to the RA and this student was hit with
several disciplinary charges including
sexual harassment first just shouting I
hit it first and this is because of the
latitude that these laws gave colleges
well once you know Department of
Education said this is what we consider
sexual harassment no college university
administrator in the right mind is going
to look at that and say I'll we'll just
ignore that they're gonna write new
policies because they don't want huge
investigations that cost a lot of money
take a lot of time and have ultimately
the potential to cost to school all of
its federal funding when it comes down
to it so we've seen the proliferation of
these really broad policies some of
which have hilarious lists of examples
of things that could constitute sexual
harassment like inappropriately directed
laughter elevator is another fire
favorite these these are all things that
are known as flirting recording or
whatever you wanna call it sure there's
a cooler term but like that's how you
meet people and sometimes it really is
and honestly it's the sexual harassment
angle has become a broader
discriminatory harassment angle because
a lot of these policies start to look
the same based on any protected class
and so when you say that you know any
unwelcome comment based on a protected
class you know they're not strong from a
particular policy or anything is
harassed discriminatory harassment well
that's a big problem
because that cuts off subjectively
whichever way you go basically half of a
debate people for instance on different
sides of affirmative action are both
going to find their opponents ideology
probably offensive of course if you are
against affirmative action for whatever
reason you might be people who support
affirmative action
say well that is discriminatory based on
a protected class race and they
shouldn't be allowed to say that we've
seen students hosting events like
affirmative action vague sales and kind
of make a point yeah about what they
think is the unfairness in affirmative
action and administrators have tried to
shut them down and sometimes it's heated
and shutting them down and you know the
I could give you countless examples of
things just like that but it's it's
dangerous because it kind of creates an
orthodoxy of what we're allowed to say
what we're allowed to think and you know
there is no position in that I can think
of that I'm and I can say actually I
think there is no position that
shouldn't be subject to challenge there
is nothing that shouldn't be susceptible
to somebody disagreeing with it public
way and starting that conversation
nobody has the right to declare this is
how it is that is I guess our collective
yeah to circle all the way back to the
beginning yeah it's our collective right
to participate in that decision of what
we believe yeah and that's why I have
such a problem with this related to the
way that the modern Left deals with
these things because if you're gonna say
all right we're not gonna draw cartoons
about certain things now I'm not saying
you should go out of your way to offend
people but once you say we're gonna
allow certain things not to be done
you've handed all of your faculty all of
your power all of your decision-making
capability over to a certain set of
people it doesn't matter what those what
those people believe in or are but then
it's like well then they know well we
got them with something we can just keep
going and going and going and before you
know it you know it's too late to fight
back I mean and again it's going to
backfire it's gonna backfire against the
people and I think that you see it
backfiring sometimes you look at the
faculty members recently who have been
targeted by outraged mobs and people
calling for their heads or their jobs
sometimes both yeah uh-huh and they
sometimes win by the way and my good
friend Brett Weinstein still does not
have a job
just recently for a more striking
example even is Fresno State around
Aurora treated you know some intemperate
and not particularly polite things about
Barbara Bush right after she died and
you're being very good hey she can do
whatever she wants I think it was pretty
nasty stuff my mother told me never to
speak ill of the dead yeah no I think
you were being nice to what was tweeted
and it was the right that was calling
for her head and weed I mean one of my
colleagues I felt really bad I was the
one who who helped write the letter but
he was the one who wrote our
public-facing uh
blog post that on the website he was
getting hate mail probably still is
getting hate mail from people saying how
could you defend this woman how could
you I mean it goes both ways everyone's
going to sense trying censor their
opponent so just really be careful right
well I'm glad you brought that one up so
basically this this woman who's she's a
professor and she tweeted some really
nasty stuff about Barbara Bush who had
just died and by by every account
Barbara Bush was a totally decent woman
but that's actually irrelevant for this
and yes then the right started screaming
and oh she should be fired she should be
fired she was not fired the Fresno State
she's still there I thought wow this is
an exact example of how free speech is
supposed to work she said what she
wanted the people mocked her or
supported her the university decided to
make a decision now it's interesting if
the university had fired her let's say
they had said these ideas are beyond the
pale and then people started digging
into some other things that she's said
that are pretty radical if if that had
happened would you guys have offered her
a defense because doesn't the university
have the right to make the decisions
that it wants I don't know what their
policies aren't on on tenure for example
or that sort of thing but don't they
have the right to employ people that
they want to be employed or not well I
want to give that power to the mob
because we know that the mob does awful
things it depends when the government is
an employer the the government actually
is restricted in what it can do for a
risk with respect respect to employees
off-duty speech
when a I think that's particularly
important with faculty members who are
supposed to be public intellectuals
they're supposed to be out there and of
discussing and debating this is what we
expect out of faculty members at
colleges and universities but when the
government is the employer and the
speeches made as a private citizen on a
matter of public concern as this very
clearly was then the government has to
make a pretty high showing that that
speech so materially interferes with the
provision of services that the
government is involved in that it
warrants overcoming the employer
employees First Amendment rights and we
actually wrote a long letter and it was
co-signed by the ACLU of Northern
California Electronic Frontier
Foundation and a whole bunch of other
organizations it under ours behalf and
sent it incidentally he shortly after
they got our letter the university
issued their statement that they weren't
going to discipline her right so you are
making the distinction in this case that
because this was not on campus this
wasn't being in a class you know taught
in the class or brainwashing students in
a class saying that's different what
she's doing on her private side and
especially because as you said as a
public intellectual you're supposed to
be talking about stuff that that's
different than perhaps if she had said
these very same things in class they
could have taken a different stance that
maybe would have had a little more legal
positioning is that fair to say that's
where it gets tricky yeah because
there's a certain the Supreme Court
back in 2006 held that speech made
pursuant to official job duties is
basically speech that's commissioned by
the government and therefore does not
have First Amendment protection you can
be fired for it but they did not decide
whether or not that would relate to
speech that relates to scholarship or
teaching as the Supreme Court put it
which is due to the special concern
about academic freedom that we have for
the reasons of
faculty members being public
intellectuals the Fourth Circuit and the
Ninth Circuit where California's have
both said that no this ruling that
speech pursuant to official job duties
does not apply at colleges and
universities to speech that relates to
scholarship or teaching so in California
she could have been protected either way
but it's not that way all around the
country some courts have declined to
find that exception to the 2006 Garcetti
ruling of others have kind of ignored it
for the time being so one of these days
the Supreme Court's probably going to
have to make another decision on that
yeah I'm curious I I know you guys are a
nonpartisan organization but if these
decisions were left up to the states do
you guys have a position on that in and
of itself I'm sure you have a personal
position but does fire have a position
on that I mean I think our our position
is that the exception for scholarship or
teaching absolutely should be applied
across the country it's really
fundamentally important for faculty
members to be able to conduct you know
controversial disruptive you know
relates to the status quo research and
writing without fearing for their jobs
because that's how we're going to get
new ideas yeah if you just talk about
things that aren't going to rock the
boat if you just research things that
aren't gonna rock the boat we're never
gonna get anywhere you you need the bomb
throwers yeah
there's room for that so what about
cases where and I guess this brings up a
little bit related to tenure because I
think there is something interesting
because it's it's funny I hear from
professors I get a ton of email from
professors saying that they love what
we're doing here and that they're afraid
sometimes tenured professors are still
afraid of the mob they know they're not
gonna get fired but they're afraid of
the mob is there an inherent problem in
tenure in a way now because you could if
you have that protection and I'm all for
saying whatever you want to say that
technically if you were a history
history professor let's say you could
start you could just start losing your
mind and teaching really dishonest
complete reversal of the truth stuff and
have the protection of not being fired
like that actually handicaps
the pursuit of knowledge from from the
university doesn't it I'm not terribly
concerned about that because generally
speaking there are ways for faculty to
be disciplined or removed even with
tenure often times for gross
professional you know competency issues
you know if you are say teaching math
and you're teaching students that 2+2 is
17 yeah I think that's in common core
you you can there's this ways of the
university can address that yeah that's
not really what we're seeing what we're
seeing more often is for instance the
professor who's you know teaching
physics who is on the side a Holocaust
denier and he's you know maybe not
necessarily teaching that in class but
does that have any ramifications for his
ability to teach physics mm-hmm probably
not that's not a competency to teach the
you know topic that you were hired to
teach things right but if it leaked into
the classroom then it's a separate issue
that's well if you are teaching a class
on physics and find some occasion to
talk about the Holocaust I think you're
probably not teaching you the thing that
you are hired then it's up to the school
to decide what to do okay that's it it's
a different problem I think that that
indicates pretty squarely along with the
denial that the Holocaust happened that
you are in fact losing your mind right
so what are some of the cases it may be
one or two cases that you guys are
working on right now or that you have
your eye on right now that you think are
particularly relevant that people should
know about well we just issued a press
release this morning in fact just a mere
hour or two before I came here at
Syracuse University where we sent a
letter on Friday this one is it's just
bananas yeah let me pause you for a
second I haven't read it yet but I
wanted to go to Syracuse to be in
broadcasting because I wanted to be like
a news anchor or or a Sports Center
anchors wrote I really wanted to be but
they're a big broadcasting school so I'm
already fascinated by this as a place
that's you know about disseminating
information well you might be glad you
didn't
this here we go a fraternity had an
event every year where the pledges or
new members would come in it was a
private event and they would do skits
that roasted the other members of the
fraternity a lot of eternities have this
kind of tradition I'm pretty sure that
mine did oh no but they went through
some skits and one of them for example
was making fun of a member of the
fraternity who was a known and vocal
Trump supporter and conservative so they
satirized him by having somebody who was
supposed to be him starting a rival
fraternity that was quote/unquote a
white Empire and to join people had to
take a horrific ly racist anti-semitic
oath and for sounds like it's all in
good fun
well whatever it may be tasteless but
all good fun and you know what their
Saturday's again it's different you see
comedians doing all the time on a stage
of satirizing people yeah another one
was they satirize one of their brothers
for being chronically whipped by his
girlfriend and portrayed him as mentally
[ __ ] and they had him in a
wheelchair and all that stuff
this was all on a private event and you
hear the the laughter and the audience
indicated that nobody was really
offended by it they understood this is
kind of just poking fun at people mm-hmm
the problem is that videos of it leaked
and the student newspaper published them
which you know they had the right to do
as well oh I can't begrudge than that
and of course as you might imagine
outrage erupted and the within a matter
of days the fraternity had been expelled
permanently from campus 18 students have
been charged with disciplinary conduct
by or doesn't know disciplinary code
violations and they're being threatened
with a suspension or expulsion and this
is like all right before finals and
meanwhile a an adjunct faculty member
had the gall to express concern about
how the university was handling
all this and they immediately told them
because you've used online with ours you
are no longer qualified to teach these
university unbeli and it's incredibly
authoritarian sounding I mean they are
they're just willing to steamroll over
anybody who gets in their way
in pursuit of really just giving
somebody a head on a pike so that the
crowd is mollified you know it's it's
nuts they've charged them with sexual
harassment discriminatory harassment
never mind the fact that nobody who the
speech was actually intended for
actually was offended by it it didn't
it's not their fault you know they don't
know how the videos leaked they were
posted to a private Facebook page and
somebody must have had access to
somebody's computer or something like
that but the speech was purely private
and nobody was offended by it and if
every conversation between two students
can be the grounds for disciplinary
investigation because a third party
later found out what was said during
that conversation well we'd all be in
jail yeah exactly it's it reduces free
speech to a complete nullity it's crazy
you know it's just it's really it's
galling and B just really a harsh and
punitive bent of the university and all
this is is mystifying wait so just on
the technical side now because this is
something good that Trump's done related
to this because he got rid of a lot of
the title nine expansions and all that
and DeVos and they got rid of that stuff
which I assume you agree with right
basically I mean it's stuff that we had
spent a lot of time fighting again right
okay so Obama expanded it Trump got rid
of it I think for the knee in the name
of free speech when you hear stories of
like Laura Kipnis who I've had on and
many others the the witch hunts that
happened there are crazy
so these policies that they're saying
that these students violated these have
nothing to do with government policies
right these they're saying they violated
school policies is that correct yeah
also be clear they're discriminatory
harassment policies are obviously drawn
on a lot of the same language because
they receive federal money in the form
of
student loans and things like that so
they actually still have to adhere to
title 9 even though they're not a state
institution obviously but you know they
they've been charged with this laundry
list of offenses they've the
administration has been rushing through
trying to kind of get the process over
with as soon as possible meanwhile not
giving them really a lot of details
until just recently in terms of you know
what the charges are based on and all of
this I mean it's very clearly a
steamrolling and it's it's outrageous
and you know that's kind of the most
recent thing so tell me a little bit
about how you guys get involved in that
so okay so you issue a press statement
now they are press release now they know
they have a little bit of public defense
do you guys actually work with the
students like just kind of lay out how
that whole process goes yeah so on our
website we have a form anyone can fill
out to request help and me and my team
every morning we'll go through the case
submissions and we'll review them and
you know follow up for more
documentation if necessary and like I
said we get damn near close to a
thousand of them a year now which is a
lot of work and we investigate and
develop the cases and figure out what
the best situation that's in each case
would be usually the next step involves
writing a letter telling the University
which Syracuse case we sent that on
Friday telling them hey this is the
applicable law or these the vehicle
applicable norms that you should be
adhering to as a college and here's why
what you're doing has run afoul of all
of that
generally speaking you know we'll wait
for a response in good faith to give the
university some time to acknowledge our
concerns and work through them and you
know otherwise we will excuse me issue a
press release and start bringing public
pressure to bear sometimes in public
college and university cases we'll take
it to litigation if we have to not every
case obviously because you know there's
a range of cases that are you know make
for a good lawsuit but even just
recently filed a lawsuit at Joliet
Junior College and this is kind of again
kind of flips the narrative a little bit
because the students who saw
people basically talking about how
capitalism is great and decided that she
wanted to make a good point about
socialism so she handed out huh you know
and distributed flyers about how you
know it said shut down capitalism
inviting people to like a workshop about
socialism this was actually not far from
where I live in Chicago is in the Joliet
Junior College and she was actually
confronted by a number of campus police
officers who pulled her to an
interrogation room demanded to examine
the Flyers and then confiscated them and
saying you can't do that here you know
the the political climate of you know
right now is you know you might start
something yeah I'm actually shocking to
hear it happening that that the story's
not the reverse
this is an odd one I'm glad you used it
as an example actually you know it goes
to show actually you know you'll be
interested to hear this act my my team
and I actually did a really a quick
analysis and this isn't scientific or
anything of all the public cases that
we've have on our website from the
beginning of fires history and actually
more than half of them have nothing to
do with politics more than half of them
are simply administrators having power
again and when they have the power that
will use it to regulate or silence
speech that they find inconvenient or
critical of the university or
administrators or just kind of not nice
generally less than half of our cases
had to do with speakers being silenced
specifically because of the viewpoint
they were espousing on a political level
it's you know it kind of undoes a lot of
the narrative and to be honest I'm kind
of a little bit tired of the whole
whether the right or left love
censorship more argument I think it's
completely unproductive and does nothing
to solve the problem which is we all
need to understand why protecting free
speech is important I didn't much rather
focus my time there and you know so it's
really that that whole narrative can
could use a little deconstructing for
a little bit and and I'm glad that you
know we had that case that kind of
allowed us to show it and people
appreciate it I got a lot of messages
from people on the right who said you
know I disagree with everything that
that young woman had to say mm-hmm and I
would sit there and I would yell that in
her face but you know what I'm damn glad
you guys stood up for her rights and you
know when I get messages like that it
just it warms my heart and I get them
from people on both sides saying you
know what I probably wouldn't have
reacted in the same way you did leaping
to a defense of free speech but I'm glad
you did it because I got something out
of that you know it made me think about
why my reaction wasn't that and if I if
I get if I can elicit that in people I
feel great about my day
you know just that's the heavy lifting I
think well that's a beautiful thing and
that's why I did what you guys are doing
the final thing I want to mention is
that I just remembered in this last
moment that the reason that you're here
I saw I had wanted to have one of you
guys on for about a year or so and
you've been on our master list of all
this and then I think about three months
or so ago someone tweeted at me that
they were at school at a school library
and they were watching a video of me and
Ben Shapiro and that they were reported
to the diversity office or one of these
things that it was hate speech and that
another student shouldn't be allowed to
watch these these evil things etcetera
etcetera it turns out that this was in
the UK so it was not under the
jurisdiction that you guys cover which
obviously is the United States but it
just shows that this thing this monster
that we're fighting is not local to us
here in America it's all over the world
and there are other organizations like
fire that do this work and yeah and
although it's depressing to know that
somebody's being reported for watching a
video that I put out there it's good to
know that you guys all came to the rush
you all came to the defense and you were
like who is it can we connect with them
you know I connected them with some of
your people I think and maybe you've
passed them on say yeah I don't know to
them with spikes oh okay so there's over
there yeah you know you see it happening
and all the time in the UK I mean you
can I have Google Alerts set and every
no I wouldn't say every morning but
there's more like 40,000 times a day I
get emails from Google with the latest
headlines about free speech and it's not
just even the UK in Canada there are
students protesting in India about
freedom of speech issues in all kinds of
countries Australia it's a big
conversation right now this is you know
it's is not limited to here it's not
limited to anywhere this the idea that
college campuses are kind of a both a
microcosm of society and a training
ground and a place where the ideas of
the country kind of come from in a large
sense that's a kind of a global concept
I don't think that's limited to higher
education in the United States and you
know it's I really hope that we can
convince students that's that's worth
safeguarding it's it's too important not
to well said my friend I'm with you and
for more on the fine work that Ari and
the fire folks are doing check out the
fire org
[Music]
you
[Music]